Oppenheimer might seem like a
straightforward biopic but there's a
surprising reason for the black and
white moments in the film be warned
there are spoilers ahead Oppenheimer
tells the story of The Man Behind the
world's most deadly invention but in
true Christopher Nolan Fashion the movie
is presented in a confusing non-linear
way much like in Nolan's earlier film
Memento black and white scenes are
inserted among colored ones but unlike
Memento the use of color and Oppenheimer
isn't to make the timeline easier to
understand so why the constant back and
forth will also make sense of Nolan's
confusing choice we must first
understand the true order of the film's
events and the important elements that
the black and white scenes have in
common the earliest chronological point
in the film is also one of the first
scenes shown taking place during J
Robert oppenheimer's time at Cambridge
University around 1925. after almost
poisoning his Professor Snow White style
Oppenheimer Journeys abroad to study
quantum physics meeting fellow Jewish
American theorists Isador Ravi along the
way later on during rabi's testimony at
oppenheimer's rigged Security hearing
with the atomic energy commission he
States they met in 1928 after teaching
at the California Institute of
Technology and UC Berkeley Oppenheimer
is officially hired as director of the
Manhattan Project by Leslie Groves the
character played by Matt Damon according
to his testimony in the film this
occurred in 1942 the same year
Oppenheimer apparently made his last
contribution to the anti-fascist
fighting in the Spanish Civil War
additionally when aec's special counsel
Roger Robb reveals that Oppenheimer may
have inadvertently perjured himself for
calling his conversation with Boris
pasch his attorney stated the
conversation was had 12 years ago that
roughly places the interaction in 1942
as well in the years of
follow-upenheimer's hiring on the
Manhattan Project events are relatively
clear in their order in 1943 Oppenheimer
meets with Florence Pugh's Gene tatlock
she died in January of the following
year in real life but Nola moves it up a
few months to come inside with Neil's
bore early Christmas party the film
accurately maintains the July 16 Trinity
test date in 1945 as well as the August
the date of hiroshima's bombing Robert
Dali Jr's Lewis Strauss enters a picture
though events get harder to keep track
of as stated in the film straussen
Oppenheimer met on the Princeton
University campus in 1947. historically
the incident in which Oppenheimer
humiliated him in front of the general
advisory committee occurred two years
later the closed door Round Table
meeting in which Strauss Oppenheimer and
several other members of the military
and scientific communities discuss a
response to Soviet nuclear advancement
is harder to pin down it's seemingly a
reimagining of the Oppenheimer panel
meetings that occurred between 1952 and
1953 but at the same time IT addresses
the first Soviet atomic bomb test which
occurred in August of 1949. in the film
it does appear that the scene takes
place in 1949. the newspaper announcing
President Truman's Embrace of the
hydrogen bomb program places strauss's
reveal of Klaus Fuchs betrayal sometime
in 1950. oppenheimer's aec Security
hearing took place in 1954. while
Strauss says Senate confirmation hearing
took place five years later so what does
all this have to do with the movie's use
of color you might have noticed that
Oppenheimer himself appears in every
scene of the film except for some of the
black and white ones this has less to do
with the timeline and more to do with
perspective I wrote the script in the
first person it's the only time I've
done that it made it clear to anyone who
read the script that we're on this ride
without the scenes in color are supposed
to be depictions of events are seen from
oppenheimer's eyes the black and white
ones are all from Louis strauss's point
of view this can definitely be confusing
at times but once you understand exactly
what's going on it makes the story even
more rewarding and three hours
Oppenheimer dramatizes more than three
decades of History needless to say it's
easy to get lost in time every once in a
while
[Music]